what's up everyone welcome back for
another comic-con 2022 interview this is
the other half of the cast of the show
that i love so so much if you are not
watching ghost what is wrong with you go
binge ghost it'll brighten your day
seriously congratulations on your
wonderful show thank you so so very much
we're thrilled with the response that
we've gotten for the show we're so happy
to be shooting season two we're a very
happy happy loving family and um
yeah thank you the lady doesn't taste
too much
we are a really happy very very very
content
family and it's always shoes it's most
of our first time at comic con and we've
had a blast it's been
absolutely surreal we just did a panel
with 4 000 people and i'm like oh my
gosh i'm not just talking to my sims
like i was just so hyped to be around
folks it's been a blast i mean rose
you're the pro so i assume you gave
everyone tips she's our mother i am i'm
an old hat um i love comic con it's so
fun it's so many like it's such a joyful
place it's where i don't know people
come out and get to be the best version
of themselves they get i'm so grateful
that people dress up and come from all
over the country to see
people talk about their shows and like
it's amazing it's such a privilege to
celebrate the things we love together
that's why i love it here yeah so i'm
repurposing a question i already asked
you rose because it's fun and i liked
your answer so we were kind of playing
around just for fun
so it's going to get a little dark let's
say for the four of you real you you
fall down the stairs
when you come to you're able to see
ghosts who in your life like a real
person in your life would be the first
person you tell that you can see ghosts
that would actually believe you do you
remember your answer oh gosh i know it
this is a part you didn't tell me you
were quizzing me on
something i may have said it was
jennifer morrison oh that's fair very
good choice
who is your go seeing confidant that
actually believes that you could see
ghost uh i'm gonna say
uh my my pal darcy uh she would she
would know she would she would be the
most darcy cardin everybody the absolute
hit actress would be dying to get a
dream yes exactly yeah i would tell her
yeah because i feel like she'd be the
most game ready to go wait did you say
she should play asher's sister because
that would be really interesting that
would be fun i didn't
[Music]
so who would believe you um my grandma
yuna without question because she swears
that she sees ghosts so she would be
like oh yeah okay great who's here have
you met fred i'll be like not yet
grandma who's fred so like it would
definitely be her without question
i love it mine would be my husband lap
because he believes most of the things
that i say generally and we also enjoy
believing every time we see a butterfly
we think that it's his
dearly departed uh grandmother and so
every time we see a butterfly we say ama
and so i feel like he's already halfway
on board i do that with a red bird in my
backyard it's my poppy
my whole family it always kind of does
it appear just right at the right moment
oh yeah without the butterflies for us
yeah i love that so much uh my my dear
dear friend midori francis would be the
first person who would believe me why
uh she just would she's just that's that
sang that's classic midori that midori i
see ghosts really okay
what kind what are they saying what are
they and we'd be right down down that
rabbit hole i love it that question
makes me so happy i had to bring it back
all right let's start to get into season
one and i guess a little season two rose
i'll throw this first question to you so
one of my absolute favorite scenes in
season one is the kitchen scene but i'm
wondering if we feel echoes of that
conversation in season two where
everyone like professes their love for
one another and sam is fully dedicated
to the ghost it's beautiful but i feel
like it's one thing to feel that but
it's different when you actually say it
out loud and it could change her
behavior so is that the case in season
two at all yeah i think i mean there's a
deepening that has happened between the
connections of everybody but between the
ghosts within themselves and also the
ghosts and the livings and even like jay
to the ghosts like i often say this even
though he doesn't communicate with him
directly he understands them a lot
better than sam does some of the time
he's more inclined to believe things um
he's more open-minded in a lot of ways
so i feel like um the depth and like
we've all professed love to each other
now that's like a pretty major way to go
and you've professed a lot of love
actually nige
you and nige um so there's a lot this
season that um we kind of get to unpack
further and further yeah oh we are going
to get into that scene as well but
sticking with that kitchen scene first
you do this a lot throughout the entire
season but that scene in particular does
feel like a master class in balancing
real heart and emotion and also perfect
like pitch perfect one liner so anyone
jump in on this when you're doing a
scene like that can you feel it working
in the moment do you have confidence
that that shift is happening just as it
needs to do we have the confidence
that's a really good question i think
definitely like i think that there's an
instinct to not want to make it to
saccharin right so you want to undercut
it and i think that i think what we
start to feel is maybe when it's
because a lot of times we'll just sort
of like do coverage and you're just
going to like hit that one line and it's
our editors um that do such a great job
of being able to find that balance of
tone but at the same time as a performer
i think we do try to get together a lot
of times in those big group scenes and
understand what the major
core of that
what's the fun thing that we want to
play with and then also at the same time
try to find that rhythm or that
musicality if you will if you will
rebecca save your word in order to uh
make sure that those beats are hit um
because yeah i think like the the the
death of the show is when it gets too
saccharine and you don't want any
moments like that i think we also all
believe that i mean i i feel like my
company all has impeccable taste so if
it feels like we're delighting one
another i think we feel like we're onto
something good you have a really great
moment in in oh yeah
[Laughter]
um but i definitely feel like i know
alberta was like bawling by the end but
a part of me was crying for real on on
set because i was like wow i'm really
lucky and grateful to be a part of this
incredible group of actors and it's been
such a learning experience for me being
you know as my first series regular and
these people really are dope like coming
to work every day in the middle of a
global pandemic feels i mean surreal and
this group is so special and kind and
giving so i was like oh my god this must
be the end of season one i can't wait
for season two she's gonna cry right now
i feel in these conversations and i also
think you can feel that behind the
scenes connection radiating off the
screen and that's an extra layer that
makes this show so special and really
connect with people
it's important
all right let's get back to that that
moment uh
the the reveal the final expression of
love that we've been waiting for the
entire season i was reading that that
wasn't always in the road map for him so
what was it like finding out that not
only was it gonna happen but it was
gonna be one of like the biggest beats
in the season finale
uh yeah that was it was it was nice i
think what's really fun is that it kind
of forces the character out of his own
comfort zone or it puts this character
where we don't know where he's gonna go
next which i think was really really
exciting i was really grateful that that
the writing staff decided to take it
that way which i think is good too
because you can play those fun closeted
jokes uh
a lot but then i think at some point you
want to just try to level up and like
find what that next thing could be for
that character but yeah i think it i was
surprised that he ended up coming out
myself towards the end of the season
which was nice when it's a surprise for
you like that just for you getting into
the character's headspace why did that
feel like the right moment for you oh i
think it
why did it feel like the right moment it
felt like the right moment well i think
simply
yeah yeah it had been 200 yeah the clock
was taking i think yeah it's like this
this is coming out story and it feels
like it was seated well throughout the
season um and then i think to have it
have that extra um oomph behind it
because it's been two and a half
centuries of somebody dealing with
something that people in you know the
living world go through you know in
their own time times but never that long
uh so i feel like it was like let's just
see what what happens and what comes out
and he sort of like just dips his toe
when he comes out it's a beautiful
moment that's very sweet thank you very
much all right rebecca for you i need to
ask about the possession episode first
what was the collaboration like with
utkarsh so that he could nail your
performance through his well he did such
a great job and he really deserved to go
you know to be let wild because he has a
very difficult job and
um
uh he confessed to me that he'd been
stalking me several weeks prior and he i
think understands the musicality of hedy
quite a bit and he is himself a musician
which i think goes a long way but he it
was it was a great tribute because it
wasn't a um it wasn't an impression
necessarily but he he channeled not who
hedy is in season one and who we've come
to know her to be but he channeled her
inner unleashed uncontrollable desires i
mean she would never do those things
drink all the wine and eat all the
cheetos and and you know i mean but but
she would want to and so he yeah yeah it
just it was a wonderful collaboration
i'm barely in that episode but i feel
like i'm so much a part of it you know
thanks to him his wonderful work and
because you had built such a strong
character and we were all so invested in
in heidi's journey we want to feel her
break free we want to have that so um
yeah kudos to you one of my favorite
performance beats of the entire season
is you on screen in that particular
episode and it's it's when when you say
to rose to basically not live your life
with any regrets because that whole
episode does play into the comedy of it
all especially well but there's also
this tinge of sadness that runs
throughout the whole thing so i mean
this might be me overthinking it but
what was it like figuring out how heavy
to make that line delivery so it doesn't
take away from the comedy of it but it
is the gut punch that it needs to be
well it's nice when there's that and we
this show i think does it so beautifully
there is that juxtaposition i think i
talk about how glorious gummy bears were
just moments before
and then
only in looking at rose
it does hedy discover in that moment
you you have a chance to go to paris or
whatever going to paris means to you
don't don't let it slip slip by and and
and it happened in that moment and you
know again we all
truly do have this wonderful um
partnership together on screen and such
lovely give and take and so the only
work i really had to do in that moment
is to to look at my scene part and to
look at rose and to look at you know my
character's descendant and that that
the playing of that scene felt
like it had to just be that way yeah and
and to have it be bookended by also then
i think i say some ridiculous line about
and also thank you ps and not for
nothing very very nice of you not to try
fornicating with me you know so we add
levity all the time and i think that's
what makes it work
i don't know how you guys do it all
right so for trevor now yes i love the
reveal of what the deal was with the
pants but it did make me wonder just for
your own head for some backstory
of that group of friends what do you
think it is about him and maybe what
happened before those particular events
in his life that made him the one to
step up and break the bro code
that's a great question you are really
great at this my brain's fried after a
long day of comic con but i'm still on
fire
no truly yeah no this is awesome i like
want to answer yeah yeah you wanna take
a shot at it
well here's my backstory there you go um
uh one of the the fun things about that
is
and that we move fast right so we had
like five days to figure out what is the
dynamic
of trevor with his friends that he lived
with right that that bro group right
and um
and i remember having a discussion with
the joe's saying okay so what is it that
he
is a member of this group but there's a
side of him that is beyond them or is it
that he's a member of the group who just
never belonged and it was the former
that he's in there but he's also not in
there and i think there's a relationship
with
having a younger brother in the pinkus
relationship
that um
then gets flipped with the ghost because
in
many ways trevor is the younger brother
with the ghosts and i think there's
something in that dynamic of kind of
taking care of the little guy
that pulled him in but you know not
enough for him to completely abandon the
bros or the secret and the lies and
stuff like that but enough to say
i can't i can't do both or at least i
should say yeah that he can do both that
he can take care of this guy and keep a
foot in with the group i could see it i
could feel it all right danielle for you
now when i ask about the relationship
with pete because she does kind of turn
him down in season one but i was
watching another interview you did where
you said you wanted to see that
relationship re-emerge in season two so
what do you think alberta could gain
from spending more time with pete how
can she grow
well you know first of all it's i've
never been you know a romantic interest
to anybody on tv so this is just so
delicious to be able to play with richie
moriarty who is an incredible pete um i
would also say
you know albert is a delicious diva from
the 1920s and she's raucous and you know
like she's a true teller and drinks a
lot of sazerax but also we haven't seen
you know her beautiful side of her
vulnerability and i'm i'm excited to
explore that for season two and the love
triangle that may happen between her
nancy the cholera ghost and her feet
like they literally are brandy and
monica the boy's mind like they're
fighting for their man and that's okay
and i'm and alberta's gonna win
she gonna win
i hope it gets like real intense too i'm
ready
bringing up nancy immediately brought me
back to the conversation she has with
pete where she upholds the lie and
basically says she's proud of him and
that's another moment that i just love
so so much all right group question now
what is something that your character
learned over the course of season one
that added an extra layer to them that
you've enjoyed playing with thus far
while making season two
these are these are really great yeah
i'm gonna clip this out and put it in a
reel somewhere and save it forever
this this one uh came early and it was
it was such a uh in the scope of the
season ended up being a very small thing
but i think it set up domino's for later
on the moment that trevor
thought that he might be a father
um
i don't think in the moment
had such an impact but as the season
goes on and then you get to see what
stephanie does to him
and how you know he's on the receiving
end of it all of a sudden and then being
around sam
and seeing her in a day-to-day life and
you know kind of having this access to
these women who would have otherwise
objectified and um
but i think the beginning of it was
oh my god i have a daughter
i feel like um for sam she's she's a
misfit like she have you noticed sam
doesn't really have friends around to
the mansion very often
she's um as we discover in the ghost
prom episode
i mean we dive into she's she's not kind
of thriving in a social um
setting
she is but in a different sense no well
she's found she's found one different
kind of she's found a dead crew that she
that stuck with her
and so that's been really promising
um no but but jay her husband is like
incred i think he's
much better adjusted
[Music]
no well she has no she has her um
friends and the ghost and i do think
it's the first time on a serious note
like
i think sam actually feels like
belonging i think she's got a fractured
relationship with her mom i think we
don't even know where her dad is at this
point we haven't discovered that part of
the story but we know that she is
desperate to belong and desperate to fit
in she wants so badly to impress like
jay's sister bella like that is the most
tragic desperate sort of clingy
cement at the moment and i love it
because
i think she it gives you a lot of
understanding for where her desire for
control comes from for where her um
struggles that she goes through
with trying to manage everything all of
the time come from so i i always think
of her as desperate to accommodate like
in a show about accommodation she's very
very keen to accommodate and and make
people like her force them to if she has
to
so yeah hopefully she learns something
um
for isaac i think it's just like
learning
like that alexander hamilton is
remembered
and he is absolutely not like the moment
early on in the season where he like
googles himself and discovers he is
literally a footnote in history i think
that's that's
that's sending him on a spiral path but
also in a good way in a bad way
i would definitely say for alberta it's
making her family proud specifically her
father um and i love the nugget that
they've added for in alberta's fan that
she's caribbean which i am as well too
um but something recently that i
realized about alberta in season two
um
she gets to perform
and that's all i'm kind of gonna say
about that she gets it for me to do a
little flashback into the 1920s
and
hearing the applause because i haven't
been on stage since 2016 as a theater
girl
hearing the applause for the first time
since then i was like this is what feeds
this woman and i think every time she
enters the room with a ghost she's like
expecting that and they just turn her
down and they gas lighter and it's like
well i'm still going to be fabulous so
i'm excited with pete to like you know
what i mean explore that as well too and
i think hedy for sure is like sis you
died of a heart attack she's like no i
was murdered so that it said applause
that i'm like i think she's she's always
trying to get back too
that's good and you i mean i must be i
don't know i mean because i would have
been there certainly
so that i might have something at stake
in in trying to gaslight you about this
issue um
yes brandon
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
then this flash drive by the way to the
20s which happens early in season two is
going to be
gorgeous amazing um
it's hard for me to answer that because
hedy has experienced such tremendous
growth
over the course of the season
and largely due to
the love and the influence of the of you
know the women in the house i mean she
initially is disdainful of samantha and
her harlot hair and all these things and
and she you know
she has an awakening that's engendered
by her love of alberta that women should
possibly vote and and then in the vault
episode with everyone gathered around
i think eddie realizes only in that very
moment that she's capable of moving on
and not necessarily
tied to these you know antiquated gender
roles and we'll see where she goes from
there i think she might take it a little
too far and that's all
well maybe i don't know if it's too far
she she does she
she uh she lets her she lets her hair
down a bit in season two
that's what i'll say it's like a million
more questions i could ask you i have to
let you go i know you got a dinner to
get to and thankfully season two is
right around the corner so i'm sure i'll
bug you again soon truly one of the
things
these questions are they really are so
good i don't even know if i could do a
proper outro now because my heart's
about to burst oh my gosh well if it
does i hope you become a ghost oh yes i
would like to live with all of you
seriously thank you so much for your
time today congratulations and to
everybody out there go watch ghosts
you